you say coming off three consecutive
quality starts in fact probably his best
three starts in a row as a mariner
grossman's been terrific driving this
tigers offense much improved over the
last 11 games now the 2-2 on the way to
grossman check swing it's a strike three
called on the inside corner you say
strikes out lead up batter robbie
grossman to start things off and already
they're strikeout number one so here is
designated hitter wilson ramos bases
loaded two outs no score one one-two
again to ramos on the way and it's a
swing and a miss for strike three with a
cutter and that will retire the side
huge second strikeout for usa kicucci
and the tigers leave them loaded we go
to the bottom of the first a 1-1 first
round first pick casey mize debuted last
year had hit around pretty good in seven
starts this year the results have been
better
casey mize back in the june draft of
2018 was the very first pick in the
first round by the detroit tigers
and celtic was the number six overall
pick by the new york mets in the same
draft
facing one another one one-two pitch
swinging a line drive into right field
and off the glove of scope reaching for
it
takes off his glove and that's going to
be a base hit for kelnick leading off
the bottom of the first
first two men aboard for seattle here in
the first
half to be careful here with
kyle seiger
the one-two strike three he froze him
with a 96 mile an hour fastball in the
inside part of the play
96.
seeger is
out number one
lewis hitting 253.
three home runs and is limited at bats
the 2-1 swinging a ground ball to third
base scooped up by candelario to scope
for one relay the first that's easy five
four three
inning ending double play single in a
walk to start casey mize gets three
quick outs the next two batters we head
to the second inning in seattle
scoreless tigers and mariners here's
eric haas fly ball center field this
one's deep going back lewis at the fence
looking up and it's gone a home run
eric haas
with his first
and the tigers take a one-nothing lead
here in the second
and the banner will be center fielder
jacoby jones
jones 1-1 pitch
slicing liner
fighting the lights and wins that battle
make that hagerty good job by sam way to
hang with him
[Applause]
scope lined out to jp crawford his first
timeout the strike went on scopes we're
gonna fly ball right center field this
one's got some carry to it got a chance
and gone a home run
jonathan skope goes deep to right center
oh he put a charge into it
third of the year and the tigers take a
three-nothing lead here in the second
here's jamer candelario the 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss off-speed pitch for
strike three and that'll end the inning
but the tigers
do some damage miguel cabrera getting
set to lead things off for the tigers
2-2 offering swing and a miss for strike
three
miguel cabrera strikes out to begin the
top of the third good cutter from usa
one down here in the tigers top of the
third they go good room he walked in a
3-2 pitch
you say now it's 60 pitches one out into
the third
here comes his 2-2 swing and a miss for
strength three off-speed pitch gets good
room murphy drops it picks it up steps
in front of home plate fires down to
first base to complete the strikeout
that's three straight punts out
punch-outs for you say kikuchi
and five in total tonight this is a
battle between two guys both drafted in
2018 kc mize
was first overall
jared kellnick
sixth overall
the two two swinging a miss he got him
with a high fast ball
casey mize strong through three
he's retired eight of the last nine
banners
we go to the fourth inning in seattle
lewis bounced into a double play to end
the first
the 2-2 swinging to miss wow
he just challenged lewis with a 2-2
fastball 95 middle of the plate
and lewis swung right through it third
strikeout for casey mize that had some
riding action
up in the strike zone crawford grounded
to miguel cabrera to lead off the second
candelario even with the base of third
not quite a full shift on j.p crawford
terrific shortstop for the mariners good
room up the middle but just to the left
of second ground ball into shallow right
diving stop by scope from a knee throws
got him at first what a play by jonathan
scope
he's been terrific at second base and
for him a rare start at second he's
making plays all over the place
grossman was aboard with a walk when
jonathan scope hit an opposite field
home run back in the second
the o2 pitch fastball swing and a miss
for strike three and that is eight in a
row set down by you say kikuchi
and for you say that is strikeout number
six
here's second baseman jonathan scope
jonathan is lined out to crawford at
short and he had the two-run home run
back in the third inning here's the
stretch and the one-two pitch on the way
swinging in a miss for strike three good
fastball again by you say that is
strikeout number seven and for kikuchi
back-to-back strikeouts
here in the top half of the fifth
marmalados the first baseman one of the
six left-handed mats in this lineup five
lefties and a switch hitter
the 3-2 fastball got him on the inside
corner he poured 96 in thigh high and
marmalade was frozen
haas
had a monster homer to lead off the
second the 2-2
swing and a miss strike 3 95 mile an
hour flames for kikuchi
he retires 13 of the final 14 that he
faces eight tickets punched in total
marmalajos with one of the two hits a
soft ground ball single the tigers shift
on marmaleo's lefty
wind up the one-two swing and a miss he
got him on strikes the curveball gets
marmillos
strikeout number five
ends the seventh for casey mize
tom murphy
now the wine to fan the two out of
murphy swung on belted deep to left
field haas going back looking up and
goodbye baseball over the out of town
hand-operated scoreboard
tom murphy with his fourth home run of
the season finally gets the mariners on
the board here in the bottom of the
eighth and it's now the tigers three
and the mariners won and that was a no
doubter hagerty grounded out his first
time up and walked his last time
the one two check swing did he go yes he
did
big knuckle curve down and in gets the
strikeout
donovan walton lined out his last time
up hard contact
mize working first base side the o2
fastball got him on the inside corner
93 at the knees on the inside corner
called third strike for casey my
strikeout number seven the crowd boost
that pitch squarely in the strike zone
and that will be the end of the night
for casey mize haas
with a monster home run against you say
kikuchi one for three for haas the
one-two pitch swinging a high fly ball
deep left center field going back lewis
looking up and it's gone a home run
eric haas with his second of the night
big add-on run in the ninth inning and
the tigers take a 4-1 lead here in
seattle how about it
now it's fulmer against jp crawford
the one-two pitch is swinging in a soft
ground ball in the infield charging his
candelario on the grass throws got him
tigers win
terrific defense all night long fine
play by candelario michael fulmer closes
it out on the night when casey mize
turns in a gem